yeah welcome to this video playing great
last time we colocar 1985 so look Nikita
my you're off professional player 11 12
575 well yeah there are so many strong
players on the another son okay let's
play this dis opening the flesh does
love he's played with Bishop e2 so how
is kamsky actually playing this is
playing a form all kinds of positions
and also it is playing like that often
you know getting this kind of position
okay being allowed to play Knight to c6
should be should be helpful so how to
continue now yeah probably I need to
move the light squared Bishop Bishop g4
yep shouldn't be too bad
it's a it's a very very solid position
this kind of structure with the light
squared Bishop bishops exchanged Bishop
b5 it's not really achieving much yeah
let's get the night 26 this is a good
idea okay yeah 96 anyway and can very
quickly played I don't understand that
now here I do you for
then you can go all the way back ok 44
just just simple equal position I can
take ok let's do that and night before I
limits this rook this is a not winning
any any prizes for most exciting game
ever but we might manage almost almost
complete symmetry ok anyway
so very difficult to make any any
progress always strikes is trying for
something interesting
not really I don't really think it it
helps much
okay but what am i what am I actually
playing could go for that yeah this is
very slow though 93a thought
hmm yeah what to play okay then let's do
that it's a weird but yeah and of course
you just plays a completely different
from what I expected this was one idea
I thought it would take I always have
this idea let's get this kind of counter
pin okay maybe let's do this
Bishop takes yeah counter take b5 yeah
it's very very equal ish he is a fiscal
f7 as a possible spot to attack but ok
I've got Lucas III now threatened and
this is something he needs to to look at
now mooning the porn on default but ok
I'm on 40 seconds and it's probably
still draw ok ok I didn't I didn't I
just over look at this move yeah okay
yeah it would be difficult anyway
because i used this much time of course
it was completely pointless yeah you
spent the minute empty answers in three
seconds with the with the nonsense move
but ok Luke c6 is much better I feared
this but ok and we got this which of
course I'm is just just dead equal can
then you blunder this pawn and it's just
a pawn down but it's not easy to win of
course I maybe you can do some things
black queen e five or something the only
thing I don't like the whitest
blundering the look of course I thought
this would be a good idea to use this
pin this pin but ok pin is not so bored
if you lose a look interesting however
as I'd like to see them the line before
here Roxy six I had actually thought I
thought rook c6 Roxy six this one I
thought this would be okay for me but
then
computer points out this one with a
clear edge and yeah this I didn't see be
sure a night back and then you can
actually take to ICM we have not it's
not so difficult but ok played this this
this rookie one moves instantly yeah I
spent too much time here of course
there's not much happening I can play
all kinds of news let's say this one but
I got I got really fascinated by this 93
move which was relieved odd which was
bad it didn't refute it but yeah well
this is very equal I mean he cannot he
can easily avoid to lose this pawn but
um ok me yeah thanks for watching